MALE SPEAKER: What
happened to the logo?
Actually, you know what?
Ouch.
Can't take it out, sorry.
BRIAN FORD: Need some help?
I have it on my shirt, too.
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah, I know.
BRIAN FORD: We'll be good.
MALE SPEAKER: All right.
Hi, we're back here
at Devoxx 2013.
Devoxx has been a great year,
I think, a great addition
for a lot of technologies,
Angular in particular,
and I'm here with Brian.
BRIAN FORD: Thanks.
MALE SPEAKER: Welcome, Brian.
And you're here to talk
about testing, and testing,
in particular, web apps,
JavaScript, obviously not just
Angular, right?
And you had a session
a couple days ago
about Karma, so give us
the introduction on Karma.
BRIAN FORD: Sure.
So Karma is a JavaScript
unit test runner
developed by a guy, Vojta, who
also works with me on Angular.
And what's cool about Karma
is that it kind of harnesses
real web browsers, so you can
quickly test your JavaScript
app right as you're
developing it.
MALE SPEAKER: The
quick feedback is
key, that's what
you're looking for.
BRIAN FORD: Yeah.
MALE SPEAKER: So how soon
do you run this test?
On save, or--
BRIAN FORD: Yeah, so
Karma's pretty configurable,
but the typical setup
that we have is you
start Karma when you
start developing,
and you can specify which
files it will watch.
It can even watch CoffeeScript
files, for instance,
and it'll recompile
everything, load it up
in however many browsers
you want to open up,
and have it hook into,
and then it'll quickly
give you the tests.
So for some idea of how
this works in practice,
we have something like
2,400 tests with Angular.
And when you're
developing in Angular,
you might touch
some certain part
of the framework that has
kind of a wide impact,
so you want to be able to run
all these tests very quickly.
So on each save, Karma will
run all of these 2,400 tests
in just a couple seconds.
MALE SPEAKER: Wow.
BRIAN FORD: Yeah.
So it's all about being
fast and about getting
immediate feedback so
you can immediately
see the effects of your changes.
MALE SPEAKER: But you
can also integrate this
into a continuous
integration, I suppose?
BRIAN FORD: Yeah, exactly.
We also run this on our
continuous integration server.
It has all sorts of
plug-ins and hooks,
so you can get email
notifications, it does Tap,
it does all of these
sort of things.
We run it in like
a Jenkins set up.
So it's very versatile.
It's an excellent tool.
MALE SPEAKER: So you
actually-- this is not linked--
and you mentioned CoffeeScript--
in any way to Angular.
You can actually use
it with Dart or other--
BRIAN FORD: Right,
that's the idea.
The idea is that through a
kind of a plug-in system,
Karma can automatically
recompile or transpile,
or it can do some
small subset of your
build process to get
your web app going,
and then it can quickly iterate
through and do these tests.
MALE SPEAKER: And these are
mostly unit tests, right?
Do you have anything
that goes beyond that
that could look like scenarios,
integration tests, or anything?
BRIAN FORD: So at
the moment, we do
have a scenario runner for
Angular that works with Karma,
but another Googler,
Julie, has been developing
this new tool called Protractor.
And Protractor is an
Angular-specific, I guess,
scenario runner,
but it's very cool.
And I think you can kind
of take a look at it.
And perhaps in the
future we'll extend it
so it's a bit more general.
But for now, it's very cool.
If you're developing
an Angular app
and you want a better
end-to-end experience, better
end-to-end testing
experience, Protractor
is a very cool project.
MALE SPEAKER: So one
of the reasons people--
one of the key features
of Angular, I suppose,
is the dependency
injections, which
makes it much more easy to test.
So how do you go about testing
other languages and frameworks?
Is it any harder than it
is to test Angular code?
BRIAN FORD: So it
really depends.
Like you said,
Angular's kind of been
designed from the ground
up, so that way you
can easily decompose
it into its parts
and test each in isolation.
So as long as you've done a good
job separating your concerns,
it's not too hard
to test in Karma.
But one of the cool
things is, because Karma
is using real browsers,
you can do things,
you can manipulate the Dom,
you can run parts of your app
just as they would
run in production,
and then make those
kind of checks on it.
So it depends.
I know that other libraries--
Backbone, jquery apps--
people have written plug-ins
and people have written helper
libraries to make testing
with Karma easier.
But really, as long as you do a
good job architecting your app,
there's no reason you
can't use Karma with it.
MALE SPEAKER: Great.
So this is a standalone project.
Where does it stand,
in terms of versions,
and then what's ahead
for the project?
BRIAN FORD: So I don't know what
the actual version number is
for it, but at the
moment, it's very stable.
We just kind of have
bug fixes at this point.
I'm not sure what Vojta's
plans are for the future of it.
Again, it's got
kind of this more
of a horizontal architecture.
So at this point,
future development
is more or less
about adding plug-ins
to add more options
for yourself.
MALE SPEAKER: BuilD
the ecosystem.
BRIAN FORD: Right, right.
But it's not something
that, really, you
need to add too much more
to the core of besides
if we can make it faster, or
if we can make it more stable,
somehow.
MALE SPEAKER: So what's
a good place to start?
What kind of URL can
you share with us?
BRIAN FORD: Let's
see, I think it's--
MALE SPEAKER: Thekarmarunner?
BRIAN FORD:
Karma-runner.github.io,
or something like that.
Just search for it on GitHub.
That's the best way to find it.
Karma Runner.
MALE SPEAKER: Great,
well, Brian, thanks.
That's all the time we have for.
Thanks for answering
my questions.
BRIAN FORD: No, thank
you for having me.
MALE SPEAKER: Cool.
Cheers.